it's time for drew's news your daily
rocket great to plan it good news and
with me at the desk co-captain of the
new ship rossi ross matthews
reporting for judy hi
hi drew hi rossy well we're gonna get
right into it today and first up for
anyone out there online dating and i bet
how many of you show of hands are online
dating right now
oh the rest of you are lying
thank you yeah keep your hand up be
proud why not hey listen it's you can't
fight city hall it's the current state
of the world well this is exciting then
dating um you're still looking for that
perfect first date for the online dating
world well there is a first date
suggestion now it comes from amy nobilee
a dating coach in new york city
insider talked to amy and she said that
the first ideal meetup is the 30-minute
coffee she says this is a mini date it's
a perfect screener to let you know if
you want to do more sort of like a dip
in a toe in the pond instead of going
for a whole hog skinny dip taking a
nibble of that cheese before eating the
whole wheel rossi yeah in your single
days um did you have a perfect first
date formula
[Laughter]
um
no
no
i you know didn't really date until i
was 28 i just was like i i didn't and
then i got in a 10-year relationship and
then i got out of that and then i
started dating and i you know it turns
out i was good at it i really was um and
i would have a lot of dates i wasn't
like you know i wasn't hooking up right
but i was saying but i'll tell you i
don't think the coffee date is a great
idea really why uh well a couple reasons
one if you meet up and it's great like i
suggest going to a happy hour because if
it's great you could slide that day into
a dinner right and if it's horrible
you're drunk all right
[Applause]
um
well
but can i ask you i mean are you a
coffee date kind of person well i don't
drink coffee so there's a problem right
there okay um but um
you know i i date occasionally um you
know some are good some are bad um i
never let the bad ones like bum me out
i'm always like okay whatever and then
the good ones you know well i guess they
haven't been that great um
you know but i do think the act of
dating is fun and what worries me is
that people go on a series of dates and
they think like you know i just don't
want them to ever get defeated and i
also think that like getting ready for
the date and just like honoring yourself
and having a moment like in your closet
getting ready is like the fun part and
you should play music and just enjoy the
whole ritual of like what human beings
do we're so weird we're like
let's meet up and like assess each other
and sniff each other out like a bunch of
deer in the field right and then if we
like it we'll do the next date like it's
just a part of the ritual of being alive
and that should be fun it should be fun
and light
um and um and and and i i think it's fun
i think for dating is totally a blast oh
me too i loved it i mean i'm done dating
because i'm engaged now right so we do
dates but thank you i didn't well thank
you
but i'll tell you dating was work i
realized i wanted a relationship i
wanted marriage so i put in the effort i
went on a lot of dates drew i am going
to admit this i even did a couple times
two dates and one night
i know i know i know oh no you did yeah
i scheduled a happy hour and then it was
like okay i gotta go
another day
but it's because you ha i know i am
hearing myself say it date guide just
got a little more interesting yeah
because you have to put in the work you
ha you have to do it it's like trying on
jeans you just don't stop till you find
the right pair
well also let me see a show of hands how
many people date really to find somebody
and like lock it down raise of hands
not that many in our audience how many
people go on dates to live the fun
ritual of life and enjoy themselves
more
what are the rest of you doing
are you married you've already
they're married they're not dating
you're married okay well it took a date
to get there i suppose
um or not all right well i think this is
a rich debate ross your story all right
well next up it may not be the best
place for a first date but a new study
reveals americans love to hang out in
their cars
the good news network reports that a
survey talked to 2 000 drivers and 58 of
them said that they have had
the best moments of their lives
in their car
the best mode of your lives in a car 58
of you i wonder
i bet 58 of people lost their virginity
in a car which is why
what now now it's starting to add up i'm
not a mathematician but ding ding ding
48 said they love to talk to themselves
in their cars 42 said it's a great place
to cry
alone
wow all i'm doing is driving
what what are you doing in your car um i
i also enjoy eating while i drive i
don't know if that's the safest thing
to say but it's true i'm from california
and you drive everywhere and um so i
would multitask by like you know eating
a sandwich or a burrito like while
driving so i feel very comforted and
that's when i listen to like talk radio
um because i don't want to listen to
music and eat i hate
eating while listening to music i do
because
the music is the most ridiculous thing
i've ever heard i don't like it except
for billie holliday
it just got weirder
you don't
you don't like eating and listening to
music no
music is too
sexy or sad or excitable when i'm eating
i just want to focus
i got your back even if it's insane
totally
okay and finally we're hopping over to
new zealand for this next story the
washington post reports a preschool has
a very special traffic safety officer
her name is henry and she's a hen
that's right starting at 8am henry
dawn's our tiny safety vest and roams
outside this school making sure cars
drive nice and slow around
all the students talk about a happy car
story she makes sure nothing goes wrong
and that's what i call a real hh-ic
uh is that a head
head-head in charge
bingo i'm proud of you i'm proud of you
i wonder if this hen had any formal
training or if she's just winging it
no
don't
don't you have don't you have hens at
home i have six chickens actually these
that's my real chickens those are yours
yeah on the left is blanche
um then i have sparkles pepper percy
ramona
really yeah absolutely no are you would
your chickens try anything like this or
they too chicken i yeah right i don't
know if i would trust uh them with all
due respect to you chickens
not sure i'd let them you know be in
charge of safety but
i don't want to underestimate them you
know that old joke how did the chicken
cross the road
or why did the chicken oh i'm screwing
up your joke alright
it's not even worth it
is that the joke no oh no you've got a
good job you've got to do the job now
you remember that joke how did the
chicken cross the road
in a reflective vest
protecting skull children in new zealand
[Music]